when Marvel started their Multiverse
idea this is of course an idea that has
been there in comics for a very long
time but when they put it into the movie
world I became a little worried I guess
more than worried I had the impression
that they were going to use this
Multiverse notion to bring about you
know the kind of diversity inclus
inclusion Equity stuff that is so
popular now and that they would use it
as a way to replace characters uh with
everything that is kind of uh in line
with the current political thinking and
we had a little bit of glimpse of that
where in the Loki series they seem to be
using the Multiverse notion to replace
the male Loki with the female Loki and
as the Siri goes on you know the the
this feminine female Loki becomes more
and more prominent and at the end it
seems like the series is about her or
something and you saw that also in the
uh animated what if Series where every
episode seems to be about something like
that and so I was of course thinking
that it it was a kind of a post-modern
tool because the whole Multiverse idea
is a kind of post-modern tool in itself
but then I was quite surprised when I
saw the recent Spider-Man movie no way
home and in the Spider-Man movie no way
home I saw something that I've been
thinking about for a very long time that
I've been meditating on which is the
possibility of turning post-modernism
against itself or rather transforming
the chaos and the fragmentation of of
the the and The Meta awareness and the
irony and the comment upon comment that
you find in post-modernism and turning
it into something like an apocalyptic
type of Storytelling so I think that
it's surprisingly enough in the no way
home movie we get a glimpse of that and
so that's what I want to explore with
you today of how no way home is a kind
of Spider-Man apocalypse
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
so if you're really interested in this
question you really will want to look
out for Tom Richard Roland's book
sacramental imagination in which I've
written a chapter that deals more
extensively with this and how it also
connected to the rest of comic book
history and to kind of this uh certain
themes in comic book history which which
bleed bled out into popular culture but
in terms of no way home which you have
in the no way home movie is this
break-in of the metaverse and what's
really smart and witty about the way
they did it is that they treated the
metaverse as a way to join together the
different iterations of Spider-Man
movies that have existed uh you know in
in the past 30 years or whatever and so
at 20 years I guess I don't know exactly
how long and so what happens is as The
Meta versus bridge then these bad guys
start to come in and the Spiderman come
in and it is there are three versions
three series that have existed in the
past several years one which of course
we was with Toby McGuire Spider-Man then
The Amazing Spider-Man with uh Andrew
Barfield and then ultimately the MCU
version with Tom Holland
and so what's interesting about it is it
has all the kind of post-modern
characteristics first of all it's very
meta because it treats these different
iterations of the franchises as
universes that kind of coexist which
they do in the story world and then they
take this these stories and they drag
them into one story so first off it's
something like what Avengers was in the
first place it's something like the
superhero team Motif which we've seen in
superhero comics for a very long time
which is the capacity to take
independent Creations like Spider-Man
Wonder Woman Superman which are not
created by the same people and but then
bring them together into a common story
which usually has more Cosmic stakes and
can and creates this kind of you know
Legion of Superheroes or all the
different superhero teams that exist now
there's something about that which is
very fascinating uh and in this version
and in the Multiverse version and
especially in this particular version
there's a way in which they kind of
expose the story structure of doing that
by taking different iterations of the
same story and smashing them together
into to one one giant movie
um and so there's like I said there's a
kind of self-awareness of Storytelling
in it and in the movie there's a way in
which even some of the comments about
the different characters bring this
about so a simple example is that Andrew
Barfield was part of a an iteration
called Amazing Spider-Man which was less
popular and less critically acclaimed
and in the movie The Character the
Spider-Man the Andrew barfo Barfield
character he you know kind of he kind of
uh you know uh let's say demeans himself
and Compares himself to the other
Spider-Man and says how his story is not
as good and he's not as good an
iteration of Spider-Man
to Spider-Man to which the other two
Spider-Man answer no no no you're
amazing which is a reference to the name
of his own iteration which was The
Amazing Spider-Man and so there's kind
of a funny uh comment but it's also an
interesting meta narrative it's
something like they they are showing us
the fourth wall
without breaking it like an in-story
version of the fourth wall where they're
aware of their story of their story
existence
um and they're exposing it inside the
story you saw that in in a certain kind
of
let's say uh 20th century authors like
Borges who talk who have this notion of
the you know the the characters in the
story that are self-aware that they are
characters in the story there are many
many iterations that in kind of
post-modern Storytelling so you have
that but because it's like an in-world
awareness and and it's something in a
way in which they expose the fourth wall
without breaking it which is which is
actually pretty interesting as a as a
way to approach this thing now
the most important part which helps you
show that it is an apocalypse like what
do we say what do we mean by Apocalypse
Now an apocalypse is when we talk about
a revelation like in the Book of
Revelation it's something which is with
both shows the end of something but also
is a revelation it's a revelation about
the pattern
and this is what is happening in this
this movie and so it's not just about
kind of bringing in these different kind
of Spider-Man they do it in a way that
in instead of the usual post-modern
technique which is to kind of jam in all
these different uh type of stories what
I what I tend to call it a collage type
of Storytelling so think for example of
American Gods like Neil gaiman's
American Gods where he takes all these
gods and jams them together into one
novel into one story but he does it in a
way that is that is fragmented and kind
of ironic and also idiosyncratic he's
constantly trying to show the
idiosyncrasy of these incarnated Gods as
if they're just regular people that just
happen to be Gods so you can really see
a postmodern move in something like
American Gods or the different versions
of this think uh of stories like Shrek
for example that take all these fairy
tales and jam them into one story so
this is the collage technique of
post-modernism and in the Shrek version
what you have is again a kind of cynical
inverted a play with the fairy tales in
which you kind of uh upend expectations
you turn things upside down you know uh
the hero is the ogre the princess
becomes an ogre the prince is is the bad
guy
um
etc etc etc so you you you always you're
always upending expectations you saw
many many versions of this type of of
technique whether it be again uh in the
fairy tale World there was that uh
Disney series Once upon a time there was
a DC vertigo series called fables in
which is all this kind of dark retelling
of fairy tales where all the fairy tale
characters exist together now this of
course is taken to some maybe to his
extreme in something like American Gods
where all the gods kind of coexist in
this cynical uh fragmented world that
lacks Unity now what happens in the
Spider-Man movie is it seems like it's
going to go down that road and it's
pulling in all these bad guys all these
different characters but what the story
does which is different from something
like American Gods is that it uses the
collage approach to bring about a
revelation about the Spider-Man pattern
and to bring about a way in which it is
actually kind of restored and helps you
show the unity of the pattern within its
Multiplicity
so how does it do that
first of all what's interesting about
the the Spider-Man Story the MCU version
of the Spider-Man is that it's already a
kind of idiosyncratic version of the
pattern so if you know the Spider-Man
story from the comic books the MCU
version is very odd because Spider-Man
appears you know first of all he doesn't
seem to have an Uncle Ben
his Uncle Ben obviously didn't die and
then his Aunt May is Young he's also
very quickly becomes rich and famous and
has all this power which is given to him
by being in contact with Tony Stark this
is very different from the the the comic
book character who is a teenager who's
poor who's like a struggling journalist
and he has all these kind of the
problems of a regular Joe while all the
all the while trying to be a
a superhero and the poor part is
important he's always kind of struggling
and he sews his own costume he's always
having trouble with his stuff and so
so it's already it's almost like hinting
at the metaverse in this version already
it's hinting at the variations on the
Spider-Man theme and so in the movie
what they do is that they take that and
now they bring it together and the way
they do it is they have the different
characters the different Spider-Man
character heal the sins and cover the
sins and the the lacks of the other
Spider-Man characters this is really a
very genius storytelling technique so
let me give you a few examples of how
that happens now of course
in the Spider-Man so there's a lot of
interesting things that happen so first
of all you kind of see this exploring of
Multiplicity and this exploring a
multiplicity in a way which makes you
actually see the deeper pattern and
doesn't kind of show the idiosyncratic
part of it and so like I said in the in
the original Spider-Man version
Spider-Man uh one of the part of his
origin stories is that before Uncle Ben
dies he he the one of the the last thing
that Uncle Bill tells tells Spider-Man
is with great power comes great
responsibility then Uncle Ben dies
because Spider-Man is out there you know
trying to make a bunch of money
and he lets a criminal go by him without
stopping him and so because of that
Uncle Ben dies now
that that part of the story isn't in the
the MCU movie in the first movie
iteration the Toby Maguire version you
do have that and that leads Tobey
Maguire to be to be kind of part of the
cause of the death of the guy who killed
Uncle Ben he wants to kill him and then
he does end up dying and ultimately it
also leads Toby McGuire to the death of
Norman Osborne the the the Goblin and so
this is something like the failings of
Toby the Toby Maguire Spider-Man you
know his sins and his failings the
things that weren't brought together you
could say
so in the MCU version now you have this
really surprise powerful moment when
Aunt May says to Peter Parker with great
power comes great responsibility and
when she says that although it's
completely different from the original
story when she says that if you know the
Spider-Man story it will cause an
Insight in you and you will understand
that she is going to die and you're
going to know that before it happens
which is something that in movies
usually they tend to want to do the
opposite they want to kind of bring
something unexpected to you and that is
what was going to cause Insight right so
I make you think that he's the bad guy
and then I then all of a sudden I reveal
that he's the the other person is the
bad guy misdirection which is which
causes Insight now this is a different
type of insight one one which we which
is actually part of very very ancient
storytelling which is a type of insight
which comes from knowing the pattern and
then seeing a variation on it that that
brings you into the pattern itself and
so when Aunt May says
with great power comes with great
responsibility
they're they're spoiling what's going to
happen you know that she's going to die
but the way they do it causes you to
have insight about the nature of the
Spider-Man pattern so it causes this
this interesting little moment of
insight
um so that is something which is going
on now in this version Norman Osborne
kills Aunt May after she said that to
Peter Parker and so this leads
the Tom Holland version at the end of
the movie to try to kill Norman Osborne
and the person that stops him from doing
that is Toby McGuire so Tommy McGuire
stops Tom Holland from killing Norman
Osborne and in doing that he is doing
three things he is healing first the
fact that that he participated in the
death of of the one who killed Uncle Ben
that he was part of the death of Norman
Osborne and he also stops this iteration
of Spider-Man of going down that path
and so they're using the variation on
the patterns to kind of heal the
different sins and so one Spider-Man
heals this his own sins and by doing
that he's also kind of covering or
preventing the other one from going down
the same dark path he has it's quite
interesting storytelling
and another version of that is of course
in the Andrew Barfield
version so in the comic books Spider-Man
loses his girlfriend Gwen Stacy Gwen
Stacy Falls and Spider-Man is incapable
of catching her and she dies and this is
seen as one of an important move moment
in Marvel Comics an important moment and
also a kind of maturation of comics
where Comics move into a more mature
form of Storytelling
now this version of the fall of Gwen
Stacy was already given a Twist in the
Toby Maguire version of the movie where
MJ Falls and Toby Maguire is actually
capable of saving her and so there's
already an interesting kind of variation
on the pattern which is about this woman
falling and whether or not Spider-Man
can catch her and in the version of the
Tommy McGuire version he does catch her
now in the the uh Andrew Barfield
version It's Gwen Stacy and he's not
able to catch her she dies
so you can see that it is this
interesting kind of variation on the
pattern and
you know it kind of shows you the
multiplicity but now in the MCU version
Andrew Barfield is the one that now
saves the falling MJ and so the MJ from
the MCU Universe She the MCU version she
falls like Gwen Stacy like the MJ from
the first uh Toby Maguire movie and
Andrew Barfield is able to save her and
in Saving her he heals his own
incapacity to have saved uh
Gwen Stacy in knowing that he saves the
the the one that his that the version of
the MCU version of the of Spider-Man
uh his own love and so it's like he's
not even doing it for himself he ends up
doing it for Tom Holland but in doing
that but also in kind of looping up his
own problem and his own sin he's able to
kind of heal himself but also prevent
that damage from going to the the
current version of Spider-Man and so
it's it's really powerful so it's taking
this weird post-modern moment of we call
intertextuality and so you have all
these threads of of text and Spa and and
um and variations on the Spiderman
pattern you know the the different Falls
and saving and not saving all the
possibilities and then it wraps it up in
a nice bow and reveals something about
the nature of the Spider-Man pattern and
kind of heals the Spider-Man pattern at
the same time so it's very interesting
and so ultimately you can see how all of
this leads to something like the end of
a world and the end of the world is
shown in the the Spider-Man movie in the
MCU version as the end of The Avengers
moment and so you see the Statue of
Liberty they're putting up this like
weird uh Captain America shield on the
Statue of Liberty and then it because of
this fight around the Statue of Liberty
The Shield Falls and kind of breaks and
it it reveals the Statue of Liberty
again and so it's the end of The
Avengers uh cycle of Storytelling it
kind of brings about a new version of
the storytelling and it leads to
everybody forgetting who Peter Parker is
and so there is this forgetting in death
but the forgetting is also at the same
time a very powerful remembering
remembering in the sense that because
the forgetting of Peter Parker happens
in Peter Parker sacrificing himself what
ends up happening in the movie is
something like a return to the the
garden
and return to the Garden in this virgin
or maybe something like a New Jerusalem
or a Heavenly Jerusalem coming down
in the Virgin it means that it's a
recapturing and a re-entering into the
original closer to the original comic
book version of the story and so the
movie ends with uh the Tom Holland
version of Spider-Man
basically becoming poor again becoming a
kind of unknown guy uh all the people
that I realized knew who he was now
don't know anymore so he moves into this
in this like slimy New York apartment
and you feel like he is now closer to
the Spider-Man pattern that we knew from
the 1960s when when
um when Stan Lee
wrote the character and so it this is
what I am thinking of when I can see
this as a kind of you could call it
something like a Spider-Man apocalypse
so what's interesting and I think what's
important for us to understand is of
course I mean who cares about Spider-Man
what's interesting about it is that it
shows us a way into apocalyptic
storytelling and it is something that
you could say that both my brother
matsir and I tried to do and are trying
to do with God's dog you won't see that
at first and the first book but as the
story progresses you're going to start
to see how what we've been trying to do
is take this moment of post-modernism
this moment of collage this moment of
Multiplicity and use it towards
something like synthesis towards
something like uh bringing back a a
universe and Universal story pattern so
it becomes like so the Spider-Man movie
and this approach to storytelling we
could call it like a meta hero's journey
where it's not just within the story
that the hero goes down into the abyss
and kind of comes back up but it is
actually the story structures themselves
this going into post-modernism this
breakdown of Storytelling right this
variation this kind of excess of
variation and of potentiality which now
is kind of bringing being brought back
into something like mythological a new
mythological approach or a apocalyptic
version of Storytelling so you can
imagine something like a a Bach Fugue
right where you have the statement at
the beginning and then you move into
variation and variation variation and
you're always trying actually to kind of
see hints of the pattern in the
variation within the Fugue and as you
move closer towards the end you can kind
of see the
the pattern returning and finally we
have this kind of final restatement of
the original pattern and I think that
this is something that we saw we can
imagine that the the no way home movie
was doing and it is something which I
think that if you're interested in
storytelling it is a type of
Storytelling that we need to be very
attentive to and uh can make it make it
that we are even we can explore
idiosyncrasy we can explore the strange
we can kind of use even the strange to
surprise people in a way that is
revealing a mystery about how the
pattern ultimately comes together and so
I hope this was useful everybody hope
you enjoyed it don't forget that I have
a much better version of this this video
and a fuller version in the upcoming
book by Richard Roland so check it out
and thanks everybody for your support
and I'll talk to you very soon